H
PRESIDENT, DUDA, HERE IN WARSAW.
THEY'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE, BOLSTERING
NATO OBVIOUSLY.
POLAND HAS GREATLY FELT THE
IMPACT OF RUSSIA'S INVASION.
THEIR DEFENSE FORCES HAVE GROWN
IN NUMBERS AS WELL SINCE RUSSIA
STARTED INVADING ITS NEIGHBOR,
AND WHEN WE GOT HERE IN WARSAW,
WE SPOKE WITH SOME OF THE NEWEST
POLISH RECRUITS ABOUT WHY
THEY'RE SIGNING UP FOR POLAND'S
VERSION OF THE NATIONAL GUARD.
SOME OF THEM HAVE NEVER HELD A
GUN IN THEIR LIFE.
THEY ARE TEACHERS, FARMERS,
BANKERS, AND EVEN AN ASPIRING
OPERA SINGER, NOW VOLUNTEERING
FOR BASIC TRAINING IN WARSAW.
THEY ARE DAYS AWAY FROM
GRADUATING AND BECOMING INFANTRY
PERSONNEL, THE POLISH VERSION OF
THE U.S. NATIONAL GUARD.
WHEN RUSSIA INVADED UKRAINE, AND
PLACED WAR ON POLAND'S DOORSTEP,
THEY SAW RISE IN RECRUITS.
NOW THE DEFENSE MINISTER EXPECTS
RECRUITS TO REACH 50,000 IN THE
COMING YEARS.
>> AWARENESS IS THE FIRST STEP
OF THIS.
>> Reporter: FOR POLAND, THE
COUNTRY WITH THE LOWEST GUN
OWNERSHIP PER CAPITA IN EUROPE,
THE INVASION BECAME A NATIONAL
CALL TO ARMS FOR PEOPLE WITH DAY
JOBS.
>> WE SLOWLY TURNED CIVILIANS
INTO SOLDIERS.
WE TEACH THEM THE STRUCTURES.
WE TEACH THEM HOW TO WEAR THE
UNIFORM.
WE TEACH THEM HOW TO BEHAVE.
WE TEACH THEM WHEN TO SALUTE,
WHEN TO NOT SALUTE.
>> Reporter: MARY, A 36-YEAR-OLD
MOTHER OF TWO, NOW FINDS HERSELF
BALANCING LIFE AS A BANKER ON
THE BATTLEFIELD.
>> I'M VERY HAPPY THAT I HAVE
THIS POSSIBILITY TO WORK AND TO
BE A SOLDIER.
>> Reporter: 22-YEAR-OLD LAURA
IS AN ASPIRING OPERA SINGER WHO
JOINED THE TDF IN SOLIDARITY
AFTER BEING SHOCKED BY RUSSIA'S
BRUTAL INVASION.
>> YOUNG PEOPLE, WE ARE SHOCKED
ABOUT THE SITUATION, AND WE WANT
TO HELP THE UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: AND HAVE YOU EVER
HANDLED A GUN BEFORE?
>> NO.
NO.
WHEN I CAME HERE, IT WAS MY
FIRST -- FIRST CONNECT WITH
EVERYTHING MILITARY.
>> Reporter: DID IT SURPRISE
YOU?
>> A LITTLE BIT, YES, BECAUSE
IT'S HEAVY.
>> VERY HEAVY.
>> Reporter: LAURA'S TWIN SISTER
JOINED THE TDF BEFORE HER, AND
THEIR MOM HAS ALSO JUST APPLIED.
>> YOUR MOM IS JOINING TDF?
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU'RE IN FDF AND YOUR
SISTER?
>> Reporter: LAURA, MARY, AND
THE REST OF THE RECRUITS UNDERGO
16 DAYS OF BASIC TRAINING,
GRADUATING, AND THEN REPORTING
ONCE A MONTH.
>> IN TDF, YOU HAVE TO LEARN HOW
TO CRAWL BEFORE YOU WALK.
>> Reporter: PUTIN'S UNPROVOKED
WAR IN UKRAINE PROMPTING CIVIL
READINESS NOT SEEN IN EUROPE IN
DECADES.
>> YOU'RE SEEING THEM TURN INTO
AMAZING SOLDIERS.
>> Reporter: DESPITE THEIR
DIFFERENCES.
>>> ONE THING UNITES THE
TERRITORIAL AREA.
>> EVERYONE YOU SEE BEHIND YOU
LOVES THEIR COUNTRY, AND
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS, EDUCATION
LEVEL, EMPLOYMENT, THEY ALL LOVE
POLAND, AND THEY ALL WANT TO
SERVE WITH A FLAG ON THEIR
SHOULDER.
PATRIOTISM IS THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR.
>> PATRIOTISM IS THE COMMON
>> Reporter: IT WAS JUST AMAZING
TO SPEND SEVERAL HOURS WITH
THEM.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PIECE.
LIKE, REALLY, REALLY GREAT.
>> Reporter: IT WAS GREAT.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEVER
EXPECTED TO SEE, AND ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE GIVING SO MUCH FOR
THE CAUSE FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE, IT WAS FASCINATING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Reporter: YOU GUYS KNOW WHEN
A STORY LIKE THIS, IT TAKES A
TEAM EFFORT.
BETTY AND CLAY AND ANTONIO, WE
WERE ALL OUT THERE SETTING THIS
UP.
IT WAS AMAZING TO SEE THESE
EVERYDAY, REGULAR PEOPLE WHO NOW
HAVE NEVER HELD A GUN IN THEIR
LIVES AND THEY'RE SIGNING UP TO